I'm gonna get so many followers
Never never doing that again, I'm never doing that again
Hi everyone, it's Charlie. This is gonna be my spider-man far from home post credit scene and video for the ending
There's so many big things that they set up there are two post-credit scenes
Hopefully you've had a chance to see the movie if you're brand new to the channel
We're still doing that IMAX ticket giveaway
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
And leave a spider-man comment on the video. If for some reason you have not seen the movie yet careful for spoilers
There will be a rampant spoilers because we'll be talking about the end of the movie in all the post credits
so starting at the end of the movie spider-man manages to get back his spidey sense which Aunt May
Affectionately names the Peter tingle earlier in the movie. It turns into a big joke. So using his spidey sense
He's able to defeat Mysterio's very real illusions that they're creating with a combination of Iron Man's BA our effing technology
Which we learned earlier Mysterio himself created when he was still working for Tony Stark
He's a former stark Tech employee that got fired
He combined that technology with weaponized drones created by the scientist from Iron Man 1 in a big call back
He was the person that got yelled at by Obadiah Stane for being incompetent
So quick Mysterio explainer just like in the comics
He was lying about everything and he's the master of illusion
But the way they create the illusions is just a little bit different when Quentin Beck was still working for Tony Stark
His life's work was what became the be ar effing technology
Tony fired him after he lost his shit during a Captain America Civil War
Flashback to the scene where he's talking to his parents as a child using the technology
So Mysterio feels like he trashed his life work and that's what his big Vendetta is. My life's work and he names it barf
he gathers a team of other people from Stark Industries that were either fired or people that hated Tony Stark and they create what becomes
Mysterio's big plan during the movie the whole MacGuffin of the movie was the Edith glasses which are sort of a backdoor to all of
Iron Man's weaponry and technology all over the world
So when Spiderman is about to take the glasses back Mysterio says that he has
Contingency plans because he senses that Peter is going to defeat him Peter seemingly watches him die with his own eyes
Thinking that it's real because his spidey sense doesn't go off in the Edith AI system tells them that there are no active illusions
But Mysterio does two things as part of his contingency plans
He one records and edits special footage of their fight to make it look like Spiderman was the villain the whole time into secretly
I think the idea is that Mysterio used practical effects not illusions to fake his death
Sleight of hand to trick spider-man's spidey sense. And so that no illusions would be detected but the movie doesn't answer that question
So if Quentin Beck is still alive out there, we won't find out - a future movie
But I think the idea is that he is and he would return for sinister six action in a later film
But then spider-man and MJ go back to New York City with everyone
He confronts Aunt May and happy about their relationship there kind of a thing during the movie
They played for comedy like they just say well we're friends with benefits. We'll see where it goes
He takes MJ web-slinging through New York City. They have a funny scene of her just freaking out
Oh, we're never gonna do that again. Totally crazy
But then as he's getting ready to leave a news broadcast
Starts about their final fight in they air the fake footage making spider-man look like a villain. This is the first mid-credits scene
It's very important
Not quite as big as the second post-credit scene for Marvel phase 4 stuff
But this definitely teases something that's gonna be happening during Marvel phase 4 during the footage Mysterio looks into camera and obviously he's faking everything
Saying spider-man attacked me for no reason
He says that he's the only one who's going to succeed Iron Man, although this belongs to him
It makes it look like spider-man orders this giant drone attack
If you're a big fan of Tobey Maguire era, you're gonna love this next part too because then it was revealed that Jay jonah
Jameson of The Daily Bugle
Dotnet is the person who screamed the video and gave it to the news service in its JK Simmons back doing Jay jonah
Jameson in the MCU
They change it a little bit
So it's more of an Alex Jones conspiracy person's spin on what he's doing with the Daily Bugle
That just feels like it's updated for a more contemporary environment
So he's doing more video hit pieces on spider-man instead of traditional newspapers because not that many people read traditional newspapers anymore
So he just looks a little bit different but it's the same basic idea
He's gonna start running a bunch of hit pieces on spider-man spider-man is terrible. Everyone should hate him
JJ says that Mysterio is probably the greatest
hero that the world has ever seen he tries to make him sound like he was even better than
Ironman at the end of Avengers end game then
Here's the second part - Mysterio's video where Mysterio outs Peter Parker's secret identity as spider-man
Putting his picture up for the world to see so the entire world knows now that Peter Parker is spider-man
Spider-man slaps his face and has the same
WTF reaction that Aunt May had it's the exact same line that she added the end of spider-man
Homecoming when she walked in on him getting into costume and found out that he was spider-man WTF
I assumed that JK Simmons J jonah
Jameson will be a bigger character during spider-man 3 they haven't announced what the story for that is
But this mid-credits scene is basically a teaser for the biggest problem that he's going to be facing going into that
next spider-man
Film is is it how is he gonna deal with this now that all of his villains are gonna call open season on Peter Parker
Spider-man they all know who he is so they can find out where he lives where his friends live
They can come after Aunt May now
Which is exactly what happened in the comics during Marvel Civil War when he publicly outed himself as spider-man
It's right out of the comics
What ended up happening after that too is that they had to do the one more day?
storyline
The only way for Peter to save Aunt May from dying because someone had finally gotten to her was to go to Mephisto
Broker a deal which wound up erasing his relationship with Mary Jane now obviously, they're not gonna do one more day in the movies
It'll be a little bit different
But remember the spider-man homecoming post-credit scene with scorpion and vulture scorpion wanted vulture to tell him
Spider-man's secret identity now. He doesn't need to he can see it on the news
So this just paves the way for a sinister six movie later on whether that's going to be spider-man 3 or it's gonna be some
Other movie after that we don't how long it's gonna take to get to sinister six
But this is setting the stage for a more Dark Reign type of territory because yes
Nick Fury has stuff going on in the other post credits scene that I'll talk about in a second
But the world still needs another Iron Man figure that role is still empty because Mysterio just poisoned the world against spider-man
The second post-credit scene I think is even bigger for the future of Marvel phase 4 they played it for comedies
So I think that a lot of people didn't pay too much attention to what was happening, especially at the very end of it
But they revealed that Nick Fury and Maria Hill had been
Scrolls this whole time the entire movie every time you saw them
They were Scrolls
masquerading as those - it was Talos in his wife from the Captain Marvel movie that had come back they even for shattered it at
The beginning of the movie in the opening scene in a couple times there after the first time they have dialogue Maria hill calls
Nick Fury, Nick
Everybody calls me fury. Not Nicholas, not Joseph, not Nick just
Fury fury kids
Nobody caused him Nick. Everyone calls me fury
That should be the first giveaway that they're not the real Maria hill and Nick Fury
Then later when Mysterio is explaining the multiverse to spider-man for the first time Nick Fury says he's from Earth
Just not yours instead of saying are earth
so as they're driving away Talos talks to his wife about how upset he is that Mysterio was able to fool him with all these
illusions a shapeshifter
It's embarrassing
they call Nick Fury and tell him that he has to come back because things just went completely off the rails and you learned the
only
Reason that they were supposed to be pretending to be Nick Fury Maria hill was is because he asked them to execute the final part
Of Tony Stark's will give the Iron Man glasses to spider-man. That's all they were supposed to do
They weren't supposed to get involved with any of this Mysterio stuff
So Talos is admitting to completely messing up the situation with Nick Fury being off on vacation
They revealed that he's on a beach but the beach is actually an illusion itself
Just another wink at the whole Mysterio plot with the illusions and he's been taking a short vacation
Break on a giant space station in orbit that looks like the sword station from the comics as if they're teasing
Toward for Marvel phase four another indicator that this is actually the sword Space Station of the comics
He yells
Everyone as if he's in charge tells them to get back to work and who's seen my shoes because he's walking around without shoes on
The reason why that's a big deal is is because sword
Teases very big cosmic threats that Nick Fury is preparing for shield was designed to deal with earth-based threats emanating
From earth sword is all about dealing with bigger
cosmic threats the annihilators the Celestials
characters like Galactus any big
Space-based fleet or threat you want to think of so that feels very much like a Marvel phase four wink and it's a big reference
To his very first post-credit scene at the end of the first Iron Man felt teasing The Avengers initiative
You're part of a bigger world stark and he's getting ready to tell him about the Avengers
So it's sort of a bookend to his original post credits scene
But also setting up the next big team that he'll put together the next Avengers team
There's been rumors about them doing an ultimate steam. That would be something that they would do on that space station
They even have a couple cosmic teasers during the movie
There's a teaser for Nova when they're doing all the movies on the airplane
the joke is is that the world has developed movies and television shows and
Documentaries to talk about the things that have happened the last couple of years. So there's a movie about the snap
There's a movie called finding Wakanda. There's a movie called hunting Hydra
There's a nova documentary with Erik Selvig teasing the Nova character obviously and then there's an Iron Man one called heart of iron
So even though it's meant to be a very funny scene Talos saying, I'm sorry, Nick Fury
I kind of screwed up even though I gave the glasses to the kids things got kind of dicey
It's actually doing way way bigger things for the future of the MCU
I know you have a thousand other questions about Norman Osborn's sinister
six Green Goblin all the other big
spider-man villains that they might do with in the spider-man films and then all the other big Marvel phase four stuff that they teased during
The movie so be a bunch more Easter egg videos this week if there's any really big questions that you want me to make videos
For just let me know in the comments but congratulations to AB gamers
You're the giveaway winner for my last big Marvel video
Please email me on the about page of my channel so I can get your details click here for that brand new Avengers and game
Post-credit scene from the re-release and click here for that brand Shazaam black adam deleted scene. Thank you so much for watching
Everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight